la réponse est graduellement kremlin du
radio radio a dû réduire de nouveau
dérapé sur les réseaux sociaux mais non
ici on verra bien vos invités préféré
qui a nommé mes potes paris c'est pas la
bonne réponse alors un bon présentateur
pour tpm
[Applaudissements]
et pourquoi gras dur est là parce que la
bonne réponse et à chabris et déjà
puisque des singles d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis tellement fière de toi 28 mai
franchement est trop coûteux je peux à
des dizaines d'années j'ai envie de
pleurer
[Rires]
est ce que tu peux tout faire un petit
discours parce que c'est énorme
qu'est ce que tu as à dire merci il
faisait française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je vous ai compris
[Rires]
tout ça fait plaisir je voulais dire et
gras durs tu le mérites frérot parce que
tu as travaillé comme un ouf sur cet
album on embrasse aussi hustler foire
aux sports à ce que c'est une bombe
voilà il n'arrête pas il enchaîné alain
moussy enroulé tiff et frérot dame
hérité du cartonne pas travailler comme
un ouf on tue ses frais un des beaux tu
sais tout et c'est qu'on va faire un
petit boyau l'ensemble on démarre ce
week-end je ne peux pas mais je veux
partir avec vous très prochainement fort
et toi continuant ses bailleurs et je
voudrais qu'on a prise très fort grade
[Applaudissements]
ce sera dur cigale d'art